-Cecily!
-Sethily!
-It is so lovely
to have you back.
-Great to be back.
-You, like a lot of us, have
had major changes this year.
You were --
you sort of decamped.
You moved up
to Upstate New York.
-Yes, Hudson valley.
-How is rural life suiting you?
-I think I'm becoming
a real mountain woman.
I'm getting there.
I did just fall
and hurt myself, though.
My dog is actually more of
a mountain woman than I am
and she's taken it on herself
to hunt the woodchucks.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
And I --
-Not a big dog, your dog.
-Not a big dog.
-Okay.
-And not a big woodchuck.
-Okay, so it's fair.
-Yeah, it's a fair -- So,
she just fought a woodchuck.
-And how did you get hurt?
-So, I had just gotten
out of the shower.
This has nothing to do with it
except for that I threw on,
like, a housedress.
I was just gonna take her out
to pee quickly.
Wasn't wearing underwear.
And then I saw that Lucy --
I saw a woodchuck kind of leap,
and I knew my dog was in a fight
with a woodchuck.
So I ran.
I fell down the hill.
Gave them all a real view.
-Yeah.
-All the woodchucks.
And then I had to...
Like, I can't see my dog
kill a woodchuck,
and I can't see a woodchuck
kill my dog.
And it was very dramatic.
I was like, "Lucy, no!
Please! Kevin!"
And then I finally
yanked her up,
and Kevin, who I live with now,
came outside and was like,
"Are you okay?"
And I was holding Lucy and I
truly went...
[dramatically] "No, I'm not."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so glad
you added that detail
about Kevin being
someone you live with
'cause I thought you had
named the woodchuck.
-Oh, no.
-That, like...
-I wouldn't choose --
Well, Kevin is a good
woodchuck name, actually.
-I also feel like this is...
People who live in rural areas,
when they fear people from
cities moving there --
everything you did
is what they fear.
-Yeah,
but they're probably like,
whatever she's doing wrong is
all the woodchucks are there,
and then they're not there.
And then, like, the woodchuck
ran away and I truly --
then it was all like you could
hear them like --
[ Chittering ]
Like, "What happened to you?!
Are you okay?!"
[ Laughter ]
-That's great,
that they want to, you know --
I mean, if something interesting
happens to a woodchuck,
you want to tell
the other woodchucks.
-Right, I'm glad they took care
of their friend.
-I didn't know...
Again, I've never heard
an impression of a woodchuck.
That was excellent.
But I also heard --
I didn't know deers --
I've seen a lot of deers
this past year --
-Is it deers?
-Deer. You're right.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Boy.
Now it's happening
in real time.
-So you're a real mountain guy,
too, yeah.
-I think if you -- if they are
beloved to you --
-They are your deers.
-Your dears, yes.
-Yes.
-Yes, it's like...
Okay, sure, they're also deer...
-Okay, yeah, yeah.
-But my dears.
-Yes. Alright.
-But have you -- you've had
a deer scream at you?
-Yes, last summer.
And I didn't know it was a deer.
I didn't know deer scream.
-I didn't know that either.
-And I was outside again
with my dog, in a dress.
I was wearing underwear
this time, and...
And I just heard this like --
"Cawww!" or something.
-[ Laughing ]
-I can't --
it's such a weird sound.
I had to go try
to, like, google it.
And I kept looking around like,
"What is that?"
And then finally, like --
"Haaah!"
And I looked again and there was
this, like, deer staring at me.
And I was, like,
for the first time in my life,
afraid of a deer.
-Yeah.
-Of deers. Of my dears.
-[ Laughing ]
-They were not my dears
in that moment.
-They were no longer
your dears then, yeah.
-And we went inside.
But I feel like
this has also been...
I have googled
so many animal sounds
for like my last --
the last year and a half of my
google searches is like,
"What sound"
or, "What animal makes a sound
like a cat but angry
in the middle of the night,
Hudson Valley, New York?"
[ Laughter ]
I have, like, a bird --
I have two bird sound apps.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Being like, "What goes like
da-da-da-da-da-da-da?"
and then trying to...
but that's hard to google.
-Yeah, 'cause what do you --
Do you make it into the app
or do you wait for the bird?
-I've tried to, like,
phonetically try to write out
the sounds that I'm hearing.
-Okay.
-But people do.
-How often have you...
Have you ever had a hit
from the app
telling you what kind
of bird it was?
-I've, at least, assumed that it
was right,
that I was identify--
-Don't take this the wrong way.
Like, based on the noises you're
making,
I feel like the best it could do
was either like a binary
"Yes, that's a bird"
or "No, it's not a bird."
-Well, I think I know...
It's that whatever goes like,
"Da-da-da-da-da-da!"
Whatever that is, is like
a starling or a robin, I think.
-Okay, that's great.
-Yeah.
-We -- I did --
Well, like, we had a game that
anytime a bird made a noise,
I would tell my boys that was
the bird saying hello.
And so then
they would yell back.
So it would be like that noise
and then be like, "Hi, bird!"
And then the bird -- you know,
because the bird wasn't
having a conversation --
would just say it again.
And then the kids would...
So then I had to tell them,
"You have to -- you can stop
saying hello to all the birds,"
'cause it backfired
pretty quickly.
-Just too much?
-Yeah, my kids, they were
saying hi to all the birds,
and I just -- I forgot that
the birds would keep talking.
"You don't have to keep
doing this."
-Yeah, they'll respond.
-They will respond.
I want to talk about
your wonderful book,
and we're gonna do that.
We'll be right back with more
from Cecily Strong.